توقعات بزياره واشنطن اليوم في اول رحله
خارجيه له منذ بدا الحرب
تحذير دولي لطالبان من تقويض علاقاتها
بالمجتمع الدولي بعد اغلاق الجامعات امام
الفتيات
وماسك يقول انه سيتنحى عن منصب الرئيس
التنفيذي تويتر
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نصره الله من العربيه قالت مصادر المركيه
متطابقه من رئيس الاوكراني
في اول رحله الله خارجه اوكرانيا الحرب في
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير الماضي ويتوقع
ان تشمل رحلته ايضا زياره للبيت الابيض
وبينما تدخل الحرب على قرار يا شهر التاسع
يجددوا الرئيس الروسينا اليوم يحدد اهداف
الجيش بلاده للعام 20 23 وذلك خلال
اجتماعا مع كبار القاده العسكريين وفقا
لما اعلن عنه
وبتزامل مع هذا الاعلان حضر مسؤولون
عسكريون غربيون من احتمال عوده التصعيد في
الهجمات الروسيه على اوكرانيا
وتحديدا بين الاراضي بلا روسيه حليفه
بوتين الاولى في هذه الحلقه
مباشر مباشر
قصارى جهدها لضمان اقصى درجات الامن
واحترام حقوق وحريات المواطنين
قواتنا في تلك المناطق بالمعدات العسكريه
تاكيد اللي ما نشرته العربيه مره وزير
التعليم العالي في حكومه طالبان
بافغانستان باغلاق الجامعات امام الفتيات
وحمل القرار الذي حصلت عليه العربيه
وصالات الرياضه والملح
هذا لو حضرت مبعوثه الامم المتحده الخاصه
لافغانستان
الدولي عبر اتخاذ قرارات لا تحظى بالشعبيه
حتى بين الافعال
لن تلتحق الفتيات بالجامعه هذا القرار لا
يحظى بشعبيه كبيره بين الافغان وحتى داخل
قياده طالبان لقد تم انتقاده من قبل
الاسلام
في المجتمع الدولي بالتزامني مع ممارسات
تنتهي كوك حقوق الانسان وخاصه ضد الفتيات
ميسي
تسعى اليه طالبان من المجتمع الدولي يبدا
بالشرعيه التي يكتسبونها من الشعب
الافغاني من خلال افعالهم
في ختام يا اعمالي مؤتمر بغداد للتعاون
والشراكه في دورته الثانيه الذي استضافته
الاردن صدر بيان الركزه على دعم جهود
العراق لتحقيق التنميه الشامله والعمل على
بناء التكامل الاقتصادي كما اكد الوقوف
الى جانب العراق في مواجهه التحديات
ومكافحه الارهاب لتعزيز الامن والاستقرار
وعلى مبادئ حسن الجوار وعدم التدخل في
شؤون الداخليه واحترام القانون الدولي
واعتماد الحوار سبيلا لحل الخلافات
بين الاردن والنصر والعراق
والمشاريع الاقتصاديه التي تم الاتفاق
عليها بالاضافه الى مشاريع التعاون بين
دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي والعراق بينها
مجالات الربط الكهربائي والنقل وبناء
الجسور
المملكه وقوفها جنب الى جنب مع العراق
وترجمتها فعليه تحقق نتائج
العراق الاقتصاديه والتنمويه
التام لاننا مائها ورخائها
يرتباطا وثيقا لنبات بنباه ورخاء جيرانها
والمنطقها
رئيسه مجلس الوزراء العراقي محمد شيعه
السوداني اكد خلال كلمه القاها في المؤتمر
سعي العراق لبناء علاقات جيده مع دول
المنطقه والعالم مشدد على نبيده لن تسمح
باستخدام اراضيها منطلقا لاي اعتداء على
دوله اخرى
وثيقه ومتوازنه مع كل الشركاء الاقليميين
والدوليين
وينها بنفسه عن اصطفافات المحاور واجواء
التصعيد
وينشدوا سياسه التهدئه وخفض التوترات وفي
ذات الوقت يرفض التدخل بشؤون الداخليه
ومس سيادته او الاعتداء على اراضيه
ولا يمكن اعتماد مبدا القوه في في مساعي
حل الخلافي او الاختلاف ولا نسمح باستخدام
هذا المبدا ضد العراق بنفس الوقت لا نقبل
ان ينطلق اي وتهديد من العراق ضد اي دوله
من دول الجوار او المنطقه
بدوره جدد الرئيس الفلسطيني
قال رئيس مجلس القدر يسير اليابانيه رشاد
محمد العليبي في لقاء خاصه به قناه
العربيه بان اداره الامريكيه ترد على
الادله التي يتم تقديمها والتي تثبت تورط
طيران باليمن بانها غير كافيه
ان نقنع المجتمع الدولي وفي المقدمه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ان هناك
وكان ونسلم ملفات بوثائق وادله متعدده
وكل مكان وفي امريكا الى صنعاء كنا نسلم
ها للمتمردين
دائما يقولون ان الادله غير كافيه قال نحن
مقتنعين في البنتاجون
ان هذه جماعه تتبع ايران ومدعومه من ايران
ولكن من يقنع البيت الابيض
تتابعون ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد قليل
استقبال الحافل في الرباط لمنتخب المغرب
بعد وصوله للمربع الذهبي في المونديال
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم من جديد
سيتم في الربع الاول من العام المقبل
من جهه الثانيه كده البيت الابيض جمودا
الموقف الراهن بشان الاتفاق النووي مع
ايران وقال مناسب الاتصالات في البيت
الابيض
وفي رساله عبر الفيديو طالبت مجموعه من
البرلمانيين السويديين من الايرانيين
توحيد وتنظيم جهودهم للاطاحه بالنظام
الايراني في حضون ذلك شهدت مدن ايرانيه
عده بينها العاصمه طهران احتجاجات الليليه
ردد خلالها المحتجون شعارات مناويه للنظام
الايراني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مين
[موسيقى]
السعوديه
هوت العمله الايرانيه الى مستوى منخفض
مجددا مع استمرار الاحتجاجات الشعبيه من
جهه وغياب اي مؤشر بشان تسويه الملف
النووي الايراني من جهه اخرى
الدولار في السوق الايرانيه الحره ارتفع
حديثا مره اخرى حيث تم تداوله عند سعر
39.760 تومانا
دعوه رساله للجان دعم المعتقلين الفرنسيين
في ايران الى تحرك منسق من جانب الدول
الاوروبيه
اللجان بعثت رساله الى الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون تؤكد فيها انه ينبغي
لاقرار ان استراتيجيه باريس في التفاوض لم
تفضي الى اي نتيجه كبيره
وطالبه الرجال من الرئيس الفرنسي عاده
النظر في الاستراتيجيه الدبلوماسيه وذلك
من اجل وقت معاناه المعتقلين الذين
يتعرضون للابتزاز من قبل سلطات الايرانيه
الرساله ذكرت ايضا انا غالبيه شركاء فرنسا
الاوروبيين لديهم مواطنون محتجزون لدى
السلطات الايرانيه
الرئيس مكرون على اللجوء الى مجلس اوروبا
على طهران من اجل عوده المواطنين الى
ديارهم شرطا مسبقا لاي علاقه دبلوماسيه
طبيعيه
هذا وتفيد سلطات الفرنسيه من سبعه فرنسيين
معتقلون في ايران بينهم المدرسين
والنقابيه سيسيل كوهلر وزوجها جاك باريس
[موسيقى]
اعلنا الملياردير الامريكيه الى مصر عبر
تويتر انه سيستقيل من منصبه ولكن عنده
عطوره على البديل وقال باسقي تغريده
اللهب الرئيس التنفيذي بمجرد ان اجد شخصا
مجنونا بما يكفي لتولي الوظيفه وبعد ذلك
ساقوم فقط بتشغيل فرق البرامج والخوادر
على حد قوله
[موسيقى]
تحركاته
للتخلي عن رئاسه مجلس اداره شركه
هنا العاصفه تسبق العاصفه الى الهدوء ساحه
الطائر المغرد ومنذ السيطره عليها الى
ماسك وحالها في تقلب دائم بدايه من البيع
والشراء ومرورا بتعليق حسابات بعض
الصحفيين واخيرا وليس اخرا على ما يبدو
استفتاء مديره التنفيذي استفتاء شكلت
نتيجته اكثر من 57% مؤيدا لاستقاله الماسك
انقسام المستخدمين للمنصه قابله انقسام
اخر فماسك لا يمسك وحده بكل مفاصل منصه بل
هناك مستثمرون اخرون قلت او كثره نسبتهم
وهؤلاء منقسمون ايضا حول تحركات لهم ماسك
للتخلي عن رئاسه مجلس الاداره ووفقه
اكتروس مشينا الى ان اعلان ماسك التخلي عن
مجلس الاداره مرتبط بوجود بديل والبديل
انه وجد بطبيعه الحال ستكون تبعيته لمصر
مالك كما يعضد فرضيه ان نتخلي يا ماسك عن
مجلس الاداره لن يغير الشيء باعتباره
المالك ما يشير الى ان التغيير قد يكون
صويا وليس جوهريا المساهمون البعض منهم
يعتقد ان ماسك قد فعل الى حد كبير ما قال
انه سيفعله تقليل التكاليف وزياده
المشاركه الم قصير المدى لتحقيق مكاسب
طويله المدى يقول متفائل بالمقابل يخشى
اخرون من خسائر كبيره جراء ما يحدث من
اجراءات على المنصه خاصه بعد ان توقفت
اعلانات وغادر موظفون
هدى تقف شبكه التواصل الاجتماعيه هذه بين
جناحيه سياسات يراها البعض غريبه ويراها
الاخر مقبوله بعض الشيء سياسه حولت هذا
المكان الى ساحه هي والهدوء والاستقرار
الى خصام في خضم خوف على مستقبل غامض يحيط
بالمكان ومن فيه عصام عبد السلام العربيه
بعد رفض السماح لهم بالعمل
خطوات الغد اتخذتها السعوديه في سنوات
الاخيره لجذب الاستثمارات في القطاع
السياحي من ابراج
مشاريع عملاقه وتغيرات تدريبيه في نظام
التاشيرات والنتيجه فرص استثماريه في
القطاع تقدرها
[موسيقى]
من العام الجديد ستبدا المشاريع العملاقه
في السعوديه مثل الجديه والبحر الاحمر
في القطاع السياحي
القمه العالميه للسياحه وسط تسجيل اكثر من
ثمانيه الاف مشارك من بينهم 250 رئيسا
تنفيذيان لكبرى شركات السفر والضيافه
عالميا جوليا سمسم رئيسه مجلس العالمي
للسفر والسياحه لا خاصه ما يحدث في
السعوديه قائله انما يحدث من تحول في
السعوديه هو ثمرته استثمارات بلغت 800
مليار دولار والذي يعتبر اضخم مالا في
تاريخ قطاع السفر والسياحه هذه
الاستثمارات الحكوميه التي تنظمها
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للسياحه والتي اطلقت
عام 2019 هي مشجع اساسي لتدفقات رؤوس
اموال القطاع الخاص ولكن استثمارات
الحكومه وحدها لا تكفي وهنا تبرز اهميه
الخطوات التشريعيه والتنظيميه التي
اتخذتها السعوديه لتحفيز القطاع السياحي
ومنها التغيير الشامل في نظام التاشيرات
السياحيه
احد القطاعات الاكثر استفاده من رؤيه
المملكه 2030 حيث تقدر الوكاله الفراسه
لاستثماريه التي يولدها القطاع السياحي
بين مشاريعها وبنيه تحتيه وغيرها باكثر من
500 مليار دولار
وفرت هذه الفرص الاستثماريه حتى ما التوفر
منصه واحده امام المستثمرين من القطاع
الخاص وهو الدور الذي يلعبه صندوق التنميه
السياحي منذ اطلاقه في يونيو الماضي والذي
يعمل على استقصاء برؤوس الاموال الى
القطاع الذي سيضيف عشره في المئه للاقتصاد
السعودي بحلول العام 2030 سعره حمدان
العربيه
قدمه من اهداف قطر وتحقيق المركز الرابع
على العالم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
عالميه
خضرابول جاء حلمنا عاديه لع
قيل وليد
[موسيقى]
الرجلان شو دراني ياسين بيقولوا ولد بلادي
وهذا شلون سجل عليه
[موسيقى]
فالتام تذكرهم بابرز العونه
توقعاتهم بزياره واشنطن اليوم في اول رحله
خارجيه الله منذ بعدين الحرب
تحذير دولي لطالبات من تقويض علاقاتها
بالمجتمع الدولي بعد اغلاق الجامعات امام
الفتيات
وباسكاكولا
عن منصب الرئيس التنفيذي لتويتر
بمجرد ايجاد
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]